dans une salle grenon plein à craquer
les français n'ont pas eu à forcer leur
talent pour venir à bout de la formation
nippone en trois sets 25 20 25 19 25 21
un succès tranquille qui leur assure la
première place du groupe d et donc la
qualification pour le final four de la
ligue mondiale
le premier set maîtrisé de bout en bout
qui laissait déjà peu de place au
suspense
le deuxième aura été un peu plus
accrochée mais rien à faire les bleus
sont au dessus et déroule face à des
japonais valeureux mais trop limités
physiquement malgré une belle abnégation
défensive les visiteurs ne parviennent
pas à inverser la tendance
la france n'avait encore concédé aucun
set face au japon en deux confrontations
il en aura été de même hier soir comme
un symbole c'est l'ancien tourangeau
earvin ngapeth qui offrent sur un
plateau la balle de la victoire
neuvième succès d'affilée pour les
hommes de laurent tillie qui auront
l'occasion de battre demain à rouen
toujours face au japon le record de la
plus longue série victorieuse en ligue
mondiale établie par les pays-bas en